this is a rare site in Sri Lanka's
present economic crisis new hires for
the railways Department the government
had Frozen Recruitment and lowered the
retirement age to 60 across the public
sector in order to save money
but some like sumeda sumaratna says this
is not the way
if State sector workers retire their
pension has to be paid a salary when
they are working on contract and
overtime must also be paid whereas if
they are given an extension the
government will have to pay just one
salary
the retirement rule forced over 20 000
workers out of their jobs on December
31st sending ripples across the country
dozens of trains were canceled and the
health sector was thrown into chaos with
some hospitals reportedly losing their
entire staff of specialists meanwhile
government plans to increase electricity
prices for a second time in five months
have been met with stiff resistance from
Regulators
if the proposal to increase electricity
comes from the cabinet we are ready to
nullify and reject it at a time we are
seeing malnutrition and unemployment and
similar problems we don't believe that
is the time for an increase the
government is determined to go ahead
with the hike Consulting the Attorney
General about how it can proceed without
the commission's approval
rate hikes and painful cuts to
government spending are required to
secure a 2.9 billion dollar bailout from
the international monetary fund
experts say it is a vital Lifeline for
Sri Lanka as it struggles to confront
the worst economic crisis in its history
the IMF guidance is very important to us
yes it's going to be a very painful for
a shorter period but if we don't go
through this painful period if you don't
go through these decisions
and make adjustments and reforms to our
fiscal policy
I believe the situation in Sri Lanka
would get worsened than what we
experienced in March April May June
periods President Ronald Vikram Singh
who previously served as prime minister
during the height of the economic crisis
is Keen to show he's in control
presiding over the first working day of
the new year
for decades successive governments have
implemented populist measures such as
subsidizing fuel and electricity keeping
interest low and filling the public
sector with political appointees all of
this has created a massive financial
burden
and reducing that expenditure as part of
a series of conditions to secure an IMF
bailout is not proving easy Fernandez Al
Jazeera Colombo